hello my name is high prince dalan
arcolan i believe that i alone must
become the dominant power on roshar i
must exert power over the other weak
nations strike fear into their hearts
make them beg for mercy but not anymore
though i had some weird dreams about
uniting our country we should stop
fighting amongst ourselves and fight the
real enemy those
not us people they're different so must
be bad or are they because i had some
weird dreams again and violence is bad
right like violence is a bad thing like
i used to love it but now it's like not
good anymore we need to unite every
nation on roshar as equals we must share
resources and unite collectively to
overcome a global threat
[Music]
by force if necessary and only if you
have bright colored eyes because brown
eyes are
yeah
we need to smash systems of injustice
and create a new political system but we
still need a king probably just you know
i could do it but i mean if people are
people are cool i mean i'd probably be
good at it
[Music]
you